hello my name is Erasmo governments and
I'm from Brut I'm part of them I'm
member of the welfare size of America
team and I'm here to talk about the
external services that are connected to
the warfarin language the first thing
that I want to say is that and we used
to comes and concepts here like for
example Internet services when we talk
about entry services we talk about like
a function that we can connect to as
external services also gather
information and display that information
in a particular way so for example if we
want to query the web using different
API like for example the Wilkinson surge
beam search we can use a function that
use all these external services and that
is an interest what is the service
connection a service connection is just
collection of functions that allow us to
create a connection first then choose a
request that we want to call and also
gather the information and display it so
then with with that data we can use that
export and also share if you want first
thing that I want to show you is the
integration services well it's not live
yet but we can talk about this function
that we can create that we are creating
web search what emerged image search and
language to relate this those functions
are using like Google Custom Search API
being Search API Google Translate API
and also Microsoft translator API so for
example what about if we want to a query
the web if you use it simple like web
search mantis shrimp we got all the
results that you can get into a browser
when you type mantis shrimp we can get
all this information into a data set for
example mainstream and also we can use a
we can construct all the URL is domain
for that for the result so the same is
for a web image search for example we
can we can query for the name of our
animal like for example a vicuna and we
can choose a method like for and this
guy could be Google could be being
searched if you notice they are
different because the method is
different the engine is different so
this could be useful for a data
scientist that we need to train models
with a lot of images and they can
download this function into the world
foreign language and that would be very
useful so if you use that image to image
25 that their salt is a between yeah
it's like a very cute animal from Peru
so the same way through language
translate they use the same you can use
the method Microsoft the method Google
and we know that they are different
engines and obtain different responses
and well doesn't know its final kill a
first at a company it's like a metaphor
with with you translate from spanish to
english so the other part of the of the
presentation is like service connection
service connection are all these api's
web apps or i think an external service
that we can agree elaboration with that
so for example pushbullet factual
wikipedia twitter and we can show you
more for example if you go to the
documentation we can type external
services oh yeah
and you can see that we support a lot of
API like for example in the class social
media yeah
yeah yeah those are very in known issue
that we are users working on it all
right so we can use in classes like
social media communication or a certain
texture necessary like Dropbox where you
can connect your your well for language
to drop books and maybe then using that
in the iOS version of the previous
presentation that you sure about it
so next okay so the first another thing
that I need to show you guys is like it
when you use API external services you
need to connect to that API right and we
have different ways to connect data API
so for example we have Oh - typical
dedication or AED difficult dedication
so there's another API that didn't use
one of them so for example Wikipedia
doesn't need our dedication so we can
use directly Wikipedia data as an
internal services a for example do these
kind of things we can retrieve
information and we can retrieve articles
using Wikipedia and maybe generate these
nice graphics that it shows that for
example if we if we have to receive a
article for the Central Park and those
article have the coordinates property on
them we can graphic that information for
example in this art in this area we we
have this article for example this is
the reservoir Jacqueline Kennedy or
maybe the monument from Alexander
Hamilton and so so what are things we
can deal with Wikipedia so repair we can
find that in an article have different
links different different data for every
article so we can for example M
try to count count 30 count
the share of cerebral links between
different kind of articles in this case
we can find the closest friends for
friends and we know that for example a
the kind of this shareable link share
links are more M are more dominant in
Rachel Greene and Monica Geller so that
could be right awesome
when when we want to use another type of
of API like for example ready a it needs
a lower type of dedication in its a
while for example what if I want to use
these decent education let me quit the
kernel all right so what if I want to
use the readied service connection it it
prompts me to web serves web brought to
a browser and I need to authorize that
application that application so I'm
going to allow that application and now
I can use the the reddit a service
connection so for what where we can
receive information for a user data for
example we can check what what kind of
trophies have a user all this one for
example and also that could be
interesting if they might have a link of
us already we can retrieve information
about that about the post for example
here and I got a data set with all that
information that we are that that the
subreddit is is is that so I'm going to
import that image yep so that's already
all the alien is unexpected we Cali back
further to the to us and this is a very
good big picture that we can important
so that doesn't read it this is an hour
out of dedication and you can
access to the service can to a service
connected this service connection using
your own account okay and what about if
I want to use another service connection
that doesn't need to be connecting with
my own account and maybe use an IP key
or request token or one of those okay so
let's try this one
pushbullet is an application that can
allow us to transfer information between
devices okay between my devices for
example if I want I have my laptop I
have my smartphone here we can transfer
all this information between them across
them so let's try to connect is exactly
a it from dialogues right because it's a
a biggie so I need to copy paste my key
so this is my gig the whole thing I can
borrow that generator or is it and now
is connected so now that I have the
service object over there I have that
connection to the pushbullet API
so basically when I need to know but
then I have to do a request all the way
Jesus is pass my my API as a parameter
of the request okay so that's do you
don't have to worry about where to put
words Buddha nor or maybe which
parameter we need to use so that I'll do
that you offer you that so what about a
little sample request and what about if
I want to push a note here so it doesn't
sound oh it sounds right
so I put a note here and and you can use
that a push note for for a for that what
it was what others we
for example if I want to take a picture
from here like you guys know all right
so I take the picture here and me and I
going to transfer these to the
pushbullet application and we can just
wait for the connection yeah
okay so now that is a intro in my
pushbullet application I can reject that
information here in Wolfram language for
example if I want a history of the all
the fact that I transferred to the to
the to this application I can use the
push history the push history request I
can use that yep
and I can display this so for example
here I have all the leads that push that
I use that I am using this application
for example this is the last one camera
capture and if you see another test
order so yeah I have this and also I can
import that image here the Wi-Fi no no
no this is an Internet I know this way
so yeah and we wait for this to charge
oh there is so yeah
and we have this this this picture and
here in the phone and now is here in the
world for language that we can process
we can maybe for example when we're the
inner streets and maybe we can to take a
picture of a flower and then I need to
use image identify in in warfare
language but I don't have even so
dividing my phone maybe and we can use
that to turn
for that information to to to the to the
welfare language using using the
connection that we are working on
pushbullet let's go to Twitter so you
know what if you know how Twitter's work
also we need to use this sort of
information is low Alto dedication so
these could be did need to what maybe if
I do this there you're okay so the
saying I need to address i authorize
this application and then i can use all
the functions that we are allowed to use
in this connection for example if i want
to return the user replies for a given a
username right here I can do that I can
create I can for example get a tweet if
I know the tweet ID I can get all this
information and all these functions are
developed for this specific connection
so for example if the connections have
different kind of end points right we
work with which every every endpoint and
create different requests so only that
you need to change is that the first
parameter like user replies may be
changes for tweet tweet search hashtag
search so in the documentation they are
very explained and you can you can you
can use that documentation to maybe
create a new new post and you have new
data
so what about for if I know that ID for
a tweet for a given to it I can return
information for that tweet and also if
the do you have a for example another
metadata like images or something like
that we can also receive that
information here and this may be take a
little bit and know
okay so this is a picture that we are
related to this tweet it's the same ID
and in that way we can receive all the
information for that tweet right and if
you see is the same request only that
change they start the parameter so I
have the elements here and I can repeat
all the information of of that tweet so
what about if I search Twitter with the
hua Vista with the hashtag war friend
text from this done very cute
yeah there is so we have actual
information that that is listed here so
we can we can query that information and
maybe try to do an ally and an internal
analysis for this information like for
example we can do a work we can do try
to process in these these tweets and
maybe try to do our analysis sentiment
analysis for this for these tweets and
it's very useful for for very data
scientist for data scientist in for
example improve or we were using this
disconnection a lot so it's really good
to try to use sentiment analysis and
those tweets
oh this for example what about if I very
simple word cloud with no with no a lot
of processing just a simple work cloud
we can do that very easy and what about
if I treat that image that I he just
take a couple of minutes ago and we can
even include a message for that tweet so
in this this this this is you can see
them right so for example the request
tweet make a tweet make a call for the
connection and tweet the my message and
attach then that
image that I just take it before so
let's take a look
maybe's here yeah yeah so yeah service
connection is all these service
connection interest services is a word
that we are doing in South America and
also here and it is very useful we have
a lot of a lot of services that we can
start a service that we can aim that we
can add to this there there are there
are in um in the documentation again but
like let's take a look at this external
services services sorry buddy
nice corrector alright so we have all
these external services and we can plan
we plan to add more we support this
information on these services in PPC or
even in laptops or or in in a cloud so
we can use all these risk reduction in
every platform that you want that you
need also and that's it guys and that is
where I will working in here and working
for these sorry connection to be better
you